certains riverains qui tentaient un
moment quand même de calmer le jeu se
sont fait happer les gens faisaient
comme s'ils allaient les renverser donc
il y a beaucoup de riverains qui ont été
quand même assez choqués par cette scène
et surtout des coups de feu et on
n'était pas on ne savait pas à ce
moment-là le type de coup de société
puisqu'on savait pas si c'était un
pistolet d'alarme ou pas les habitants
ils ont ils ont flippé quoi ils ont tous
eu vraiment très très peur et c'est pour
ça que moi je me suis rendu
immédiatement à la mairie puisque c'est
un de mes adjoints qui devait célébrer
le mariage et donc je prends contact
avec l'officier de police qui était à ce
moment-là en charge de cette de cette
interpellation et je lui dis bah écoutez
moi je prends la décision d'annuler le
mariage il faut que j'aille voir mon
adjoint et pour rentrer à l'intérieur de
la mairie comme il y avait déjà un
certain nombre d'invités qui étaient à
l'intérieur de la mairie dans la salle
des mariages je me suis retrouvé à
devoir rentrer dans ma propre mairie
entourée de policiers pour justement ne
pas avoir de menaces envers ma personne
qu'on a été mis dans une pièce de la
mairie protégée par la police pour
pouvoir discuter parce que la police
avait peur justement